you know what's funny what I was uh
I I noticed I had this like little scr
you see the scrape right there that
looks like it's uh gonna lead to
something just a little a little scrape
right yeah but that's how it starts but
you see it right okay A little red right
there yeah
I'm I'm I I I'm like I don't know what
the hell it is but it's it's like this
it's been like that for a long time yeah
it's a wound that won't heal yeah so I
go to the I was actually at the doctor
for something else and I was like what
is this this won't get worse he's like I
don't know just keep tabs on it so like
all right
Weeks Later months later I'm back at the
doctor for something else I asked you
know I say what is this and he's like
yeah it's there it's okay probably it's
just a red thing you figure it out
and I'm like okay uh but I'm kind of
worried about it because it's been so
long that it's been there
and so I really start to think about
like how what is it why does this why
why is this here because it's not there
for no reason right so I'm like all
right I'm trying to keep tags of what
I'm doing every day
keep it like this so I noticed the only
thing that I do
when I keep like this is the only thing
I do is when I go into my yep jeans
right so I'm like okay well it's got to
be something there so I started really
pay attention whenever my keys like this
and then I I noticed that when I go for
my keys or whatever it is when I go for
my wallet whatever it is that's when I
do feel something okay and I I'm so like
I think it's just one pair of jeans so I
take the jeans off I look at the jeans
there's nothing there
and then I put on other genes and I keep
noticing it's happening with the other
genes too so now I'm like is something
up with my hand the way it goes into my
jeans or whatever like that
every pair of jeans I wear I'm doing
like this so I I look at every pair of
jeans there's nothing there and then
it's nothing here I go I try medicine
nothing's really helping it I wear jeans
every day so I'm finally like dude I'm
losing my mind Calvin has a little like
um has a like a science kit and I'm like
maybe if I grab the magnifying glass I'm
going to look at the genes in that way
because something's got to be up with
these genes yeah so I grabbed the mic
the the the what do you call it the
magnifying glass and I look at these
jeans and and I'm I'm looking at
studying and I see this very very very
very very very very very very
extremely tiny
diving board
and I'm like what and then I realize oh
it's because my pockets stay deep
right
true
I got I got diving I got diving boards
on my jeans right above my
because my pockets Run Deep
you know
that's too long a story to get to that
and I want my time back I have I have to
be on a plane tonight
I can't I'm busy man I can't I'm I want
an adult conversation
timing board yeah [__] dude
so all right yeah I have to carry my
money around of a backpack or something
don't use cash
hello hello
[Music]